j'adore le contact avec les autres
c'est bien en m'échappant avec une
dizaine de petites chansons en allant
dans les endroits un peu inattendus que
je trouve que c'est vraiment là où je
suis le mieux
voici sage
je ne veux pas arrêter de dire si mon
non plus
comme pour me donner un autre chance
pour jouer des prolongations
en quelque sorte
Serge Michael des chansons depuis depuis
que j'avais 20 ans jusqu'à quand j'avais
45 et il est mort avec amour défunte on
peut difficilement donner plus à
quelqu'un ce qui m'avait donné
d'ailleurs il y a une chanson qui
s'appelle une chose entre autres que tu
ne sais pas tu as eu plus que d'autres
le meilleur de moi et c'est vrai plus
que notre le meilleur de lui depuis la
mort de Serge Gainsbourg en 1991 comme
une variation sur un même thème Jane
Birkin continue d'interpréter encore et
toujours les textes de son Pygmalion
elle les déclinera sur des sonorités
orientales et les emmènera loin de nos
frontières en 2013 sa vie bascule elle
mène un long combat contre la maladie et
à la douleur de perdre tragiquement sa
fille aînée la photographe Kate Barry je
pourrais jamais rendre assez hommage à
Kate je voudrais bien être messem et de
pouvoir embarquer ces photos partout je
ferai ce que je peux
mais bon
l'essentiel qui est elle et mon compte
presque une période de silence et de
repli l'amour de ces deux filles louées
Charlotte et la musique de Serge
porteront Jane de nouveaux vers les
autres en 2016 elle repart en tournée
dans le monde entier avec un orchestre
symphonique qui revisite avec le
compositeur japonais nos bouyuki
Nakashima le répertoire de celui qui
aimait tant la musique classique
j'adore le contact avec les autres cette
bien m'échappant avec des dizaine de
petites chansons en allant dans les
endroits un peu inattendu que je trouve
que c'est vraiment là où je suis le
mieux où je sers à quelque chose
mon amour
avant d'avoir eu vent de
vous mon amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
nous aimions
le temps d'une chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à votre avis qu'avons-nous de l'amour
de vous à moi mes yeux mon amour la vie
ne vaut d'être vécue sans amour
qu'est-ce que cela vous inspire Jane
vous qui vivez seul je vis avec mon
bouledogue
et pas seul je ne supporterai plus qu'on
me dise quoi faire que quelqu'un me
parle comme un enfant maintenant comment
m'a toujours fait un peu
cette c'est mieux justement me sortir et
se rendre à mon bouledogue
la vie ne vous a trouvé que
sans amour
mais si vous qui avez volé
mon amour
[Musique]
ne vous
demande
en dansant
bienvenue
nous
nous aimions
le temps d'une
[Musique]
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]